well today we're going to talk about the
analytical engine we've already got
footage in the can as it were about the
principle people involved in this
Charles Babbage ada lovelace the
important thing now I think is to just
give you the most general overview about
how this analytical engine would have
worked if only it had ever been built at
the Ada Lovelace symposium December 2015
200th anniversary of her birth I
actually met up with Stephen Wolfram of
Wolfram and Mathematica Fame who's done
a very good blog on Ada Lovelace
computer programmer
there's also you'll see it in the info
block again a link to all the lectures
given that 200th anniversary symposium
last but not least and it relates to
this picture we're using here one of the
lectures there was by Sidney had WA it
was a very very talented graphic artist
she turned her attention to actually
researching the Babbage Lovelace story
and has done the whole thing in a
hilarious comic book she envisages as
you see here Lovelace as this impossible
detached heroine but fearfully prized
Babbage's faithful assistant here's
Charles Babbage short-tempered
thin-skinned exactly like the real
Babbage but thanks to Sidney we're able
to actually have a picture here that I
can talk to of what the analytical
engine will have to look like should it
ever be built it may get built but it'll
be years it'll be dictates before it's
ever built because one has to understand
all the Babbage's notation in his
technical drawings and that's no mean
feat anyway Sidney has decoded enough of
what must happen here it is it's
fantastic this is the analytical engine
as it would have been I'll try and
interpret this for you in modern terms
this sort of almost amphitheatre thing
at the end here
that's the CPU this is as it were your
Intel chip at the end of this thing the
whole code
or looking thing of stuff behind her
with a proud Babbage standing beside it
that's the memory and if you look more
carefully at this you'll find that the
memory consists of thousands of
positions each of which can hold a 50
decimal digit number
binary had not occurred to
mathematicians even in the early 19th
century in saying that I do know that
the mathematician Leibniz was aware of
it but you can see that even if Babbage
had been aware of it actually the
temptation will be stick to what you
know we're here to do generalized
arithmetic and we all know and
understand decimal so yes it's a decimal
machine 50 decimal places every time you
want one of these numbers there's an
elaborate mechanical way to fetch it
into the CPU and just look at the CPU
itself if it has got to store these
numbers temporarily before it adds them
or something like that then yes you've
got to have yet more of these 50 digit
columns inside here to hold the numbers
that are in the process of being
processed roughly speaking this memory
for the machine house designed was seven
meters long and the whole thing's three
meters high
it's the most enormous thing could you
drive this with a handle by hand not a
chance
little picture here that sitting is put
here of a steam engine Babbage was going
to drive the whole thing by steam for
those of you who aren't perhaps up with
history of these things please remember
this is the 1830s and 1840s Faraday's
work on electromagnetism was just about
getting underway but any idea of having
electric motors and mains electricity to
drive this thing
not till at least the end of the 19th
century turn of the 20th when this kind
of thing will become possible so yeah
you wanted to drive this thing the only
option would have been steam way beyond
even a gang of humans to turn all these
cogs so number one it says here this
door do remember that in English
notation for computers even as late as
the 40s and 50s we in the UK
to call it store in the US it was always
called memory on IBM machines American
usage has become universal we now call
that memory equally very early papers on
computing in the UK certainly Babbage
this CPU he called the mill because you
put the numbers in you mill them around
and you Adam and you subtract them and
whatever they get you know roughed up
and knocked into an answer it was called
the mill so that's the only bit of
translation you really need so where's
the program stored is that stored in
this memory here no it isn't the idea
was that this the cards that drove this
thing would be based on well-established
and very reliable jacquard loom
technology jacquard looms weave lace and
they are programmed to get the right
pattern in the lace by having a set of
cards that go over sensing rods and the
sensing rods basically every time they
sense a whole do a stitch of that
position roughly speaking so by putting
different old patterns on different
cards and having a succession of cars
just like a succession of instructions
in a program you could get a beautiful
pattern to appear on your lace machine
and there were even card punches
available for preparing jacquard cards
which are I think I'm roughly about 30
centimeters long something like that
so this was not a flight of fantasy this
was building on existing technology you
can go to a jacquard list Museum in
Macclesfield here in the UK you can see
all of this in action you might say well
how do you keep the sequence then of the
program instructions on the cards you
sequence them by tying your jacquard
cards together with binding cords down
the sides when you go into the next card
you don't have to feed it in separately
it's pulled along in by the cords that
bind the sides of all the cards together
this most amazing machine was Turing
complete now I've done a video on
children complete and what's the
requirements which are incomplete number
one you've got to have arbitrary amount
of memory well in principle on this you
could number two you've got to have a
conditional branch statement you've got
to say if this piece of data is this
then do that else do this two possible
routes through your program amazingly
Babbage's analytical engine has got if
statements built into it and going along
with that whichever way you go on the
estate 'men might need you to do as it
were we go to to a different instruction
it was all done on these cards if you
wanted to go to an instruction 10 ahead
then the machine had to arrange to just
slip ten cards on boom-boom-boom you
could count to ten and then Dean would
come the sensor odds on the eleventh
card you've done your jump and it's part
of being able to do a jump
why can't you jump back earlier in other
words do a loop yes of course if you can
do if statements you can jump backwards
you can do loops and this could and did
do loops as well was he a complete
genius did he realize what he was doing
or did he just accidentally do the right
thing but this is the thing remember the
program is not stored in the same place
as the data as it would be on a modern
one on an computer they're both in RAM I
mean great steps are taken to protect
your program RAM from being under
overwritten once it's known that that's
why the program is but in principle they
does sit in the same technology whereas
here it was moving about with your cards
and shuffle in the backwards and
forwards that caused the jumps and the
loops so what else did this have well it
did have the ability to store numbers
anywhere in memory so there was a crude
addressing system of sorts it did have
the ability to read in a number of so
called number cards so if you were to
say let's add three plus five where are
the three and the five going to come
from well the easy answer would be
getting from number cards so you put an
instruction here in your program saying
read next number card and the number
cards here which are at number
seven you would read in and you say oh
that's interesting
that's a three and you could then either
keep it in the CPU and read in the next
card or if you wanted to optionally you
could store the three and the five in
memory now if you decided to store them
and keep them for later the most amazing
thing had to happen was that you had to
take a copy of what is in the column
here representing number three and
transfer it to the place in store where
you want to hold it in other words it's
the data bus stuff being pulled in and
push back out and in typical Victorian
style it's not called the data bus it's
called the ingress axis and the egress
access now the ingress axis was for
reading stuff in from store memory and
the egress axis was for storing it back
out again but and a mom my mom has
dropped old I mean how is that
mechanically done and the answer is with
racks and pinions like you've never
dreamed of in your worst nightmares
because this is seven meters long and
the only bit of vacant memories down at
the far end
you've got to transfer the number three
seven meters down to be stored
she's cogs and rats can roll like mad
and transfer industry down to the far
end but you could you could store or you
could stall the fact if you want to but
you would retain copies in the CPU and
you would add them together the addition
was done by the barrel controllers here
that's part of the CPU and corresponds
very closely to what's sometimes called
the micro programming level inside a CPU
again for those of you who know about
the era when CPUs were really like
computers within computers they were
easier to program that way rather than
doing hardcore close to the metal logic
used to have the ability to be able to
write a program within a program as to
how to do an addition within the CPU now
that is the basis on which this is done
there are sets of barrels with pegs
coming out
them which if they rotate around in the
right way and read the two numbers that
you've put in three and five you call up
the addition barrel which swings around
on lots of levers says I am the addition
barrel reads off the two numbers there's
lots of other complex stuff inside there
because it's like an arithmetic unit
built in there as well comes the
conclusion the answers H and then post
the answer back out optionally if that's
what the program cards say to do so it's
all kind of functionally complete that
be an adder in there there'll be a thing
for doing subtractions and so on but the
the operations of it are really very
very well known to us there are other
things in here called variable cards
those really were to stipulate where
things might be stored you might have a
reader number card but you would then
optionally read a variable card to
discover which location it's to be
stored in if you want to keep a
permanent copy so you can imagine that
writing programs for this thing was not
just getting the instructions right but
also realizing that sometimes you might
need to do what will be called a store
operation in assembler level programming
well that store operation required you
to read yet another card from this stack
to find out where to store it during the
era where he was in charge of
supervising hand produced logarithm
tables it was the printing that was
always the problem typos crept in people
sent in flame note saying I bought your
seven figure log tables and there's the
following 50 errors so he always wanted
his machines if ever they got built to
have printers built in at the back so
buried around the back of this yes there
is a printer that could print out the
answer and make a permanent record
and it's very difficult for a firewall
or something to notice this because
these a valid HTTP request they're just
super slow right and you know maybe I've
just got really bad internet same time
your nose and actually particles because
you'll never have half a foot of you
never have half an electron so the
question is if each time we send only
one electron through these slits which
way does it go